there's an unfortunate trade-off when it
comes to the high price of prescription
meds in this country the only way to
bring down branded drug prices for many
people is to give fewer choices despite
huge political uproar campaign speeches
and congressional hearings pharmacy
benefit managers or PBMs like CVS
Caremark and Express Scripts are the
only ones who have really managed to get
drug prices down but PBMs are no white
knights here's how they do it
they're basically middlemen they sit
between your insurer and drug makers and
negotiate discounts one PBM tactic is to
do deals with drug makers that may for
example give them the biggest discount
and then refuse to cover similar drugs
made by competitors in 2012 there were
just 34 drugs that CVS won't cover at
the beginning of this year there were
124 and even if drugs aren't formally
excluded it can still be difficult for
patients getting advanced and often more
expensive treatments because they're not
sticking up or they haven't tried a
cheaper medicine first meanwhile critics
say companies like CVS and Express
Scripts reap big profits when they
successfully negotiate drug prices if
they negotiate a price of an $80 pill
down to $40 a chunk of those savings
often in the form of a rebate can go to
the PBM the firms say they give much of
the savings back to clients but how much
of those savings is tough to tell the
size of the rebates on individual drugs
and how much PBM is actually keep are
one of the American healthcare systems
biggest secrets as drug prices skyrocket
higher there's room for bigger rebates
which may mean bigger profits PBM
revenue at CVS has grown to 100 billion
dollars since it entered the business in
a big way almost a decade ago by buying
Caremark PBM czar a uniquely American
invention in Europe some governments
negotiate prices they also restrict
medicines to bring down prices but the
difference is European governments
aren't making money off the negotiations
it's possible that PBM exists to take
advantage of a broken US health care
system